hi everyone
um today I'm going to talk about list
agreement expansion from Commander
expansion my name is Roy and this is a
joint work with Tally calfan
the talk will be structured in the
following way I'm first going to present
High dimensional expanders which are the
structures in which we do agreement and
list agreement testing and we're then
going to see that list agreement
requires some additional structure in
the form of Commander expansion which
I'm also going to present I will then
present our results and finally give
some high level description of our
method
so as I said let's start by considering
High dimensional expanders and the
connection between High dimensional
expansion and agreement testing
High dimensional expanders are high
dimensional analogues with expanded
graphs and the objects that are that
expand in high dimension are called
Simple complexes and they generalize
graphs into high Dimensions by having
high dimensional structures in them so
web graphs consist of vertices and edges
um Simplicity complex would consists of
triangles pyramids and so on which were
required to be closed downwards meaning
that if a triangle exists then all of
the edges that make it exist and so on
we follow all of these um structures the
faces of the centration complex and we
think of them as having a dimension
specifically the dimension of a place
with base cardinality minus one meaning
that a pyramid would be a
three-dimensional base a triangular
two-dimensional base an edge a
one-dimensional base and so on
the dimension of the Simplicity complex
is just the dimension of the maximum
interface in it and we call this in
visual complex pure
um
if it's maximal faces are of the same
Dimension or of the same cardinality
we think of pure simplicial complexes as
voided objects in the sense that
um every the faces of every Dimension
have a probability distribution
associated with them and the probability
distribution of lower Dimensions is
determined by the probability
distribution of high dimensions
another structure of Interest with
inspirational complexes are Links of
faces links can be thought of as the
faces at a certain place can see so for
example if we consider this in
particular complex and this phase then
its link is going to be this graph which
essentially consists of all the edges it
can see through triangles formerly on
the link of a face is all of the place
containing and while excluding the face
itself
we are now ready to talk about agreement
testing and the object we're going to
test our assignments and assignment of
the key faces of a simplicial complex is
a collection of functions one from one
for each K phase that assigns each one
of its vertices with either zero or one
so for example if we consider this
official complex an assignment to the
two faces of it could be for example
this assignment
we call them assignment that green if it
agrees with some Global functions so for
example this assignment is not a green
because V2
um is assigned Zero by the by this face
and one by this space
assignment to be agreeing we could
change V2 and have an assignment that
agrees with this Global function
so now that we've defined an agreeing
assignment we can move on to Define an
agreement tester
an agreement tester is a randomized
algorithm that
um gets some Oracle access to an
assignment it then queries the
assignments in two faces meaning that it
looks at the values that those faces
assign to the vertices and accepts or
rejects such that the following two
conditions hold
if the assignment is a green then the
tester always accepts
and if the tester rejects with some
probability Epsilon then we can change
um ethnosed a times Epsilon faces to get
a an agreeing assignment meaning that
um would change the values that those
faces assign to the vertices
one simple agreement test that you can
think of is essentially picking two
faces that intersect each other and
check whether they agree on their
intersection
in 2017 Dino and Kaufman defined
agreement expanders as the bishop
complexes in which the simple test had
presented in the previous slide is an
agreement test
they also show that many complexes
exhibit this um agreement expansion
they also defined one alpha German
expansion as an expansion in the case
where the intersection and
is of size K in section between two and
K dimensional places are of size K which
means that um they intersect in all but
one of their vertices
so now that we've discussed agreement
testing let's move on to discuss list
agreement and list agreement testing
our basic object of study is going to be
an L assignment which is very similar to
a regular assignment except in an
assignment every face is um given all
different assignments and we call those
assignments agreeing if there are other
level functions
um such that
in every phase
um every assignment agrees with one of
the global functions so for example if
we consider distant bit of complex
um with these two vertices and we
consider this L assignment so as you can
see actually this two assignments so as
you can see this face is given these two
assignments and this space is given
these two assignments then these
assignments are a green and they agree
with these two Global functions as
these two
um assignments agree with this discover
function and these two assignments agree
with this Global function
we're interested in list agreement
testing a list agreement tester is
randomized algorithm that is given an
oracle access to some L assignment f it
then queries it on Q local assignments
and accepts or rejects such that if the
ad assignment is a green then the test
always accepts and if the text rejects
with some probability Epsilon then one
could change at the most a constant
times Epsilon of the local assignments
and getting a green L assignment it is
important to stress that in this model
we think of the queries and the changes
as happening to one of the local
assignments of each um phase and not the
the entire collection of um Global
assignments
initially it might seem like a German
testing and listed agreement testing
require essentially the same tools
for example if an agreement testing
would pick two high dimensional faces
and check whether their assignments
agree on their intersection then in list
agreement testing we could pick two high
dimensional faces and check whether
there exists a permutation under which
developer assignments agree on their
intersection
this however is not the case
consider a cycle of odd length with um
these two assignments on these edges
and note that for every vertex there is
a permutation under which this um L
assignment agrees for example if you
gamma zero this assignment increases
with this assignment and this assignment
agrees with this assignment
however the two assignments can be
interpreted as saying that the two sides
of the edge are colored in different
colors and since this cycle is above
length
um it is clear that the assignment is
not a green
we therefore conclude that we need some
additional structure in order to test
for list agreement
this additional structure is going to be
Commander expansion which we will
present next
and Commander expansion is by
considering the connection between
covering spaces and near covering spaces
so let me first Define a covering space
so given a simple complex a covering
space is a different types of complex
equipped with a projection map that Maps
every
um face surface of the same dimension
such that um
the pre-image of it I've ever face
um is a set of size n for example
um agreement of the one
um would be these two vertices in this
covering space and these two vertices in
this covering space
and every face cannot in a sense
distinguish
um between whether it is in the original
complex or
um in the covering space so for example
um V1 is the triangle that contains v0
and B2 and the triangle that contains B5
and B3 and so it would see essentially
the same triangles in um the covering
spaces
of particular interest to us our trivial
covering spaces which are the covering
spaces that are consisted of just L
copies of the original complex
the second object of Interest are near
covers net covers are essentially
covered except that they only care about
vertices and edges so
um even though that take for example
this net cover in this new cover
um you can't fill in the triangles so v0
won't see a triangle but it is consisted
of V1 and V2 but rather it would see a
copy of the one and a copy of B2
um and much like the case of proper
covers
um we also care about
um the trivial near cover which is just
El copies of the original complex
we will Define one-dimensional Commander
expanders as complexes on which the
triangle test is a good test step of
whether
um near cover is Trivial or not
the triangle test is the test that picks
a triangular condom and look look at its
images and determines whether it is
consistent like existing triangles or
Not by simply picking a starting point
and walking along the edges on the three
steps and checking whether um the work
returns to the oxygen and vertex so for
example if we take this complex
um this one is not a trivial near cover
so if we started say from this vertex
and walk the three steps we want return
to the same vertex well if we consider
this complex which is a trivial cut on
their cover I'm running the triangle
test would yields um
the same vertex and thus the first would
accept
as I said we're going to define a
one-dimensional c Commander expander
over the symmetric group with L elements
to be any simplicial complex
um on which the triangle text is a good
test for whether a new character is
Tribune meaning that a nickel passes the
triangle test with probability one if
and only if it is trivial
and if it has projection they cover what
probability Epsilon then one can change
at most um the covering of at most c
times Epsilon of the edges in order to
get the trigger on their cover
it is important to note that this is by
no means the standard definition of the
boundary expansion but rather an
equivalent definition for the First
Dimension and the terms directly from a
work visuality and a work by Tina and
Michelle
we show that any significant complex
that has sufficient expansion properties
specifically combined with expansion
over the symmetric group with L elements
in every link and one upper pyramid
expansion supports listed agreement
testing using 3L queries under some
small distance assumptions on the local
assignments
specifically
um those local distance assumptions are
that any two assignments the same face
differ on at least two vertices
we know that this um limitations
inherent meaning that without this
assumption no test can be found and that
there are non-trivial simplicial
complexes
to which this result holds for example
the spherical buildings
I'm going to spend the rest of this talk
um by giving a head of a description of
our methods and specifically I'm going
to limit myself to the case where every
two key faces that intersect each other
on K vertices have some permutation
under which their local assignments
agree with each other
in order to analyze this case we Define
a compass which we turned the
representation complex which in effect
um represents the agreement tests
it's on vertices or zero faces are going
to be the case faces of the original
complex
um its edges are going to contain pairs
of faces that are chosen by the
agreement test or in our specific case
um 2K faces that intersect each other on
K vertices
and the ways we're going to have put in
the edges is the probability that the
agreement test picks on those two faces
and high dimension interfaces would be
defined so that these would be the
weights
we managed to prove that if the original
Compass is a commander expander then the
link
um and all of its links are Commander
expanders then the commanders of the
representation complex are testable
before I move on to discuss how the
representation complex helped us um with
achieving this agreement testing let's
first consider regular argument testing
from the point of view of the
representation complex
so a regular agreement tester and picks
two high dimensional faces say the red
face and the orange face and then checks
whether the assignments given to those
two high-dimensional places agree with
each other on the intersection
this corresponds directly to picking an
edge in the representation complex
specifically The Edge between the red
vertex and the orange vent the vertex
that again correspond to those two high
dimensional places and check whether
those um the assignments to those High
dimensional faces agree on the
intersection between them
consider an edge in the representation
complex
the vertices that make up this Edge are
associated with K dimensional faces in
the original complex and thus have an
assignment associated with them
um what we're going to draw are
synthetics above that original vertex so
we're going to think of the proof that
it says as
um the original vertices with a specific
assignment and the original vertices is
just on the structure
in the list agreement case we're going
to have several of those so for example
this vectors would represent Tau with F1
this vertex would represent Tau at f2
and so on and so on
um because we assumed
um local agreement under some
permutation and because we're in some
local distance we can connect those
vertices
um
such that two of these vertices are
connected even if they agree on the
intersection between Sigma and Power
this creates a near cover flow and the
representation complex which we're going
to use in order to untangle this the
agreement structure
before we show how to use the near cover
in order to untangle the um
agreement structure of the list
agreement let's consider the optimistic
case in which we already have a
privilege um net cover
in that case we have essentially L
copies of the original complex each
equipped with some assignment Associated
to it that is that fully agrees because
we hadn't changed any Edge and those
edges are creating the first case
we can therefore use the agreement
expansion in order to create essentially
a different Global functions for the
original complex
foreign
structured for example the neck cover
um that covers this triangle
in a sense Tangles two of the copies of
the representation complex by having
this cycle of length six
which essentially belongs to two copies
of the representation complex
another example
um is if you cast back to the odd cycle
example
the near cover that is associated with
that two assignments over there would be
a cycle of length 10.
and not two copies of the cycle of
length file
therefore our first step in tackling the
general case would be correcting the
near cover
um into being triggered by changing some
of its edges
in order to do that we utilize the fact
the original compass and all of its
lanes are Commander expanders in order
to claim that in the representation
complex we can bound the number of edges
we have to change in order to get a
treatment on their cover using the
number of bad triangles which here we
take red triangles to mean triangles
that are not covered by existing
triangles
consider now um the corrected near cover
of the representation complex
this is a structure that consists of L
copies of the representation complex
in each one of those copies every one of
the vertices of the of the
representation complex has a single
assignment associated with it
we can therefore think of each one of
those copies as running the agreement
test over the original complex and given
a single assignment associated with each
K Dimension and face specifically the
assignment that's associated with the
values that represented
we will therefore try to bound the
distance of each one of those copies
from a green using the projection
probability of the agreement test
in order to ban the rejection
probability of the agreement test we're
going to note the following thing
editors will not change during the
correction process still represent
agreement as they started from
representing agreement
therefore the only edges that could um
cause reduction in the agreement tests
are edited for changed during the
correction process and because we have
an abandoned number of edges that were
changed during the production process we
have a bond of the distance
um of the L assignment from being of
green
and we can therefore derive the distance
from having L Global functions
thank you for your attention